all the management strategies that we
have today will really develop thousands
of years ago live for Pacific Islanders
things like closed areas closed seasons
for spawning minimum size limits
somebody would say like oh he's a
fisherman is he a good fisherman and the
definition of a good fisherman is not
somebody who goes out there and harvest
everything but the successful fisherman
is somebody who goes up there and takes
care of the ocean while harvesting from
the ocean
in the years since the rise of global
commercial fishing 90% of fish stocks
have been fished at or above their
maximum sustainable yield
proving a desperate need for global
sustainable fishery management
for years we've been puzzling over the
problem of showing people what's
happening way offshore out of sight or
underneath the surface of the water and
we stumbled across a system of radio
frequency broadcasts that can be
intercepted by satellites to take all of
the commercial fishing activity in the
ocean and put it on a map for everybody
to see strengthened by satellite
assisted monitoring international
partnerships have grown sharing data on
shared fish stocks before were acting
individually we were not seeing we were
not knowing now the only way you can
fish in our easy is to be compliant be
legal and then we can cooperate in a
sustainable fishing
following in the footsteps of successful
regional partnerships shared management
of shared fish stocks went global with
the ratification of the port state
measures agreement by 36 parties
covering 62 countries and the
partnerships of the safe ocean Network
agreeing shared frameworks for global
fishery management rewarding the good
fishermen and taking bold collective
steps forward toward the rhythms of our
sustainable past we in the West are just
starting to realize the frailty and and
the finiteness of the ocean when you
decide that this is your priority
it must be reflected throughout the
system it's our life the ocean is our
life
you